PURE, UNADULTERATED HATRED AND
ANGER ABOUT THE ELECTION.
>> Sean: GREAT ANALYSIS ALL
THREE OF YOU.
GREAT TO SEE YOU ALL.
JOINING US NOW, SHE IS THE HOST
OF THE INGRAHAM ANGLE, YOU SEE-
EVERY WEEK NIGHT TAKING SHOTS AT
ME AT 9:59:59, LAURA INGRAHAM
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
CONGRATS, I HAVEN'T SAID THIS,
BUT I'VE SAID IT PRIVATELY, THE
SHOW HAS BEEN SUCH A BIG HIT,
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU.
SI THANKS.
>> Sean: THE BROAD PICTURE
EXPLANATION, HOW YOU SEE WHAT
YOU SEE GOING ON, AND WHAT
SHOULD BE HAPPENING IN TERMS OF
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS HANDLING
OF IT ALL.
>> Laura: LIMIT'S START WITH
STAFF SHAKEUPS, YOU HEAR THE
OTHER NETWORKS AND THE USUAL
SUSPECTS.
BUT, WOW, THIS IS ALL OF THE
TUMULT, THE DEPARTURES IN THE
ADMINISTRATION, THEIR BIG
SCROLLS OF NAMES.
THEY'RE TRYING TO CREATE THIS
APPEARANCE, SEAN, OF COMPLETE
CHAOS IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE PRESIDENT IS UNTETHERED TO
ANY REALITY, IT'S RIDICULOUS.
WHAT HE'S DOING IS WHAT HE
SHOULD BE DOING, NAMELY GETTING
THE PEOPLE IN PLACE, 13 MONTHS
INTO THIS, WHO ARE GOING TO
SUPPORT HIS AGENDA, OF COURSE
THEY'RE GOING TO QUESTION WHEN
IT IS APPROPRIATE, BUT SUPPORT
HIS AGENDA, ADVANCE IT,
ESPECIALLY GOING INTO THESE
MID-TERM WATERS WHICH ARE GOING
TO BE CHOPPY FOR THE
REPUBLICANS.
THAT MEANS SOME ONE LIKE A
BOLTON, ALTHOUGH HE'S PROBABLY
MORE OF A NEOCONSERVATIVE THAN I
AM, MORE INTERVENTIONIST THAN I
AM PROBABLY.
BOLTON IS AGGRESSIVE --
>> Sean: HE WILL SERVE THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS AGENDA.
>> Laura: ABSOLUTELY.
THE IDEA THAT THE PRESIDENT
TAKES ORDERS FROM JOHN BOLTON IS
RIDICULOUS.
HE DIDN'T TAKE ORDERS FROM GARY
CONE ON THE TARIFFS, HE DECIDED
TO GO HIS OWN WAY.
AND HE STAYED TRUE.
TO THE PLEDGE HE MADE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Sean: HE TWEETS DAY AND
NIGHT, A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE TOLD
HIM NOT TO.
>> Laura: RIGHT.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THE FBI AND
CHRISTOPHER WRAY WITH THE
INTERVIEW ON NIGHTLY NEWS.
WHAT HE SAID, I THINK, WAS VERY
HELPFUL TO THE PRESIDENT, HE
SAID WE'RE NOT, YOU KNOW, WE'RE
NOT POLITICAL.
I'M NOT BEING INFLUENCED BY THE
PRESIDENT, NOT BEING TOLD NOT TO
PURSUE PARTICULAR
INVESTIGATIONS, THAT'S NOT WHERE
WE ARE.
HOWEVER, AS YOU'VE BEEN
DOCUMENTED NIGHT AFTER NIGHT AND
I'VE BEEN TRYING TO PICK UP THE
BATON AT 10:00, WHAT'S HAPPENED
IS A CORROSIVE ATMOSPHERE AT THE
TOP THAT I THINK HAS BLED DOWN,
AND THAT HAS HURT MORALE AT THE
FBI.
THAT HAS HURT CREDIBILITY.
AND PUBLIC CONFIDENCE.
THE UPPER ECHELON OF THE INTEL
AGENCIES AND THE FBI, THEY'RE
GOING TO CALL BECAUSE AND
STRIKES, THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
PUT THEIR FINGER ON THE SCALE
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER, EVEN IF
THEY DON'T LIKE TRUMP, THEY LIKE
TRUMP, THEY LIKE HILLARY, DON'T
LIKE HILLARY.
NONE OF THAT SHOULD HAVE COME
INTO PLAY.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU THIS,
WE'VE BEEN AT THIS A LONG TIME.
ONE OF YOUR GREAT SKILLS IS YOUR
STRATEGY.
YOU THINK, YOU'VE SEEN A LOT.
WE CAN GIVE ECONOMIC STATISTICS
OF RONALD REAGAN IN OUR SLEEP.
>> Laura: YEP.
>> Sean: POLITICALLY SPEAKING,
DONALD TRUMP IS A DISRUNTOR,
ACONNICK CLASS, HE'S HIS OWN
MAN, DOESN'T CONFORM TO WHAT THE
MEDIA WANTS HIM TO BE.
HE WOULDN'T BE ELECTED IF HE WAS
THAT PERSON.
STRATEGICALLY, KNOWING THIS IS A
DEEP STATE, KNOWING THAT WE'RE
BREAKING THROUGH ON FISA AWASES
AND -- ABUSES AND FIXED
INVESTIGATION, HILLARY, SPECIAL
COUNSEL MUELLER, WHAT ADVICE
WOULD YOU GIVE HIM?
>> Laura: I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR HIM TO KEEP HIS EYE ON THE
PRIZE.
FOR HIM, IT IS THE ECONOMY, A
STABLE, STRONG FOREIGN POLICY,
BUT NUMBER ONE HE SHOULD STICK
TO HIS CAMPAIGN PROMISES.
AND, SEAN, THIS IS WHERE I'M
GOING TO CONTINUE ON THIS
TONIGHT ON MY SHOW, DOING IT THE
LAST COUPLE OF NIGHTS, THIS GOP
OMNIBUS BILL, I GUESS HE'S GOING
TO SIGN, I'M REALLY WORRIED
ABOUT IT.
DOES NOT ADEQUATELY FUND, THE
WALL, LIKE PIT ANSWER, SCRAP OF
A FENCE.
IT IS NOT WHAT HE CAMPAIGNS ON.
>> Sean: I HAVE SOME INSIGHT, I
AGREE WITH YOU.
AND I WAS LIKE, REALLY, FUNNELED
THE WALL IF YOU WANT TO GET
RE-ELECTED FOR THE REPUBLICANS.
THERE IS OTHER MONIES APROEP
PRAILT PRATED, WILL BE
APPROPRIATED, WE'LL HEAR ABOUT
IT IN THE DAYS TO COME.
>> Laura: IF WE LOSE THE HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES IN NOVEMBER,
AIN'T GOING TO GET A WILL.
HE NEEDS TO GET THE PERMANENT
FUNDING MECHANISM.
MY ADVICE, MUELLER IS GOING TO
COULD WHAT MUELLER IS GOING DO.
HE CAN GIVE GREAT SPEECHES ABOUT
HOW THIS ECONOMY IS GOING TO
CONTINUE TO HUM.
WE'LL TAKE ON CHINA.
THIS IS WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN,
WILL HAVE A BIT OF UNCOMFORTABLE
MOMENT WITH CHINA BECAUSE OF THE
TARIFFS.
IT HAD TO HAPPEN.
WE HAD TO REBALANCE TRADE.
HAD TO HAPPEN.
MUELLER, LET MUELLER DO HIS JOB,
GIVE GREAT SPEECHES ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE.
>> Sean: IGNORE MUELLER, IGNORE
THE MEDIA.
>> Laura: IGNORE THE MEDIA, TALK
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
REMEMBER HOW YOU GOT ELECTED.
>> Sean: GOOD ADVICE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY ELECTIONS
ARE WON BASED ON VISION,
PROSPERITY, IF YOU'VE BEEN IN
OFFICE, AND ON PEACE, IF YOU
KEEP YOUR PROMISES.
I DON'T THINK IT'S ANY MORE
COMPLICATED THAN THAT.
>> Laura: LAW AND ORDER, SAFETY,
PEOPLE WANT A SAFE SOCIETY.
LAW AND ORDER, STOP GIVING